what if there is no space travel what if
we're in a simulation and this is the
final season
why would this uh that well it's just
entertaining and obvious
to entertain a hypothetical it would be
an entertaining season you know
kind of it's it's like jumping the shark
jumping the shark a little bit i think
it's early on in the show like season
two
season three because we just got tv no
it's too absurd
like every like when donald trump won it
was clear that the writer was like uh
donald trump becomes president like that
wrote viewers back it's like episode
seven season two but then
when you really think about it that's
that's sort of novel to us but
historically
stranger things have happened that
donald trump becoming president though
that was let me tell you that night
my goodness none of us expected it i
didn't it's like the new york times
meter was 99
hillary clinton yeah what'd you think
that night i was laughing really hard
actually
my brother tells this story my brother
tells a story that he called me like i
was literally laughing hysterically just
because i thought it was silly like
there was not a single angle i could
examine it from that was not really
really funny
like there was this woman who was just
unbelievably crooked and
has all of the traits that make a really
savvy and unscrupulous politician
has spent her entire life striving for
one single political position
and then this one guy wakes up one
morning and he's like i could be
president and he beats her and to me
that is comedy
it is it is and i love that line trump
was like i ran for president one time
i'm sorry i'm sorry that i ran for
public office one time
and i became president that's hillary
and it is just like walking on stage
with that big smile
and you can't always get what you want
was playing
and oh i i'm telling you dude i was i
was in tears laughing i just
you can't always get what you want he
loves that song it's hysterical
it's so funny and then i guess hillary
didn't come out john podesta was like
we're gonna go to bed we'll be back and
then
there was no like yeah talk about the
salt mines that day
i know you were if you were a salt miner
you were rich that night oh my goodness
yes you were
well so i one the one regret i really
have for my college experience
is that i did not have any any classes
scheduled the day after the election
took place
and my friends did and from what they
said like there were kids crying in
class he said one of the teaching one of
my
friends at a teaching assistant like
started tearing up as they were
explaining the situation
one friend sent me like a snapchat of a
student under a desk crying i mean it
was bad
and it's funny because the media was
plastering these images
everywhere of people on their side of
the political aisle crying which
revealed something interesting about
their psychology which is that
we thought we were like they thought we
were going to see that and sympathize
with them right
can you imagine if trump had lost and
trump supporters were crying
they would have found that hysterical
and if fox news or some right-leaning
network tried putting that out there to
gain sympathy they would have been
scorched
yep so it's just a fundamental inability
to see somebody else's perspective
like like someone's like well my taxes
won't get raised then i'll be better
able to feed my family no one's going to
take my guns but i wish i didn't make
that liberal arts student cry
like what have i done so what do you
what are you going to do if joe biden
wins
i'm going to cry are you going to go no
i don't know i don't know laugh
i'm going to laugh dude i honestly i
have no idea
i have and i have no idea earlier in the
year before covet happened
and before the economy crashed i would
have said there's no way
anyone else could win i mean all trump
had to do
was not be a fascist not be hitler
and he wasn't a fascist and he wasn't
hitler so he basically surpassed the
expectations that the media set up for
him he did and
and and i'm you know he knows but that's
the thing i'm understating like he
actually did well the economy was okay
he hasn't started any new wars
he's actually been a good president in a
number of ways though he's certainly
left something to be desired
um if not much the point is
it wasn't until covet happened that i
thought oh like maybe he doesn't have as
much of a chance not that i'm blaming
him for it but it's very easy to see how
that narrative is going to be run with
like
we are under his watch and things aren't
going very well so many conspiracy
theories that
it was intentional together i've heard
on this yeah yeah i don't i don't
jump on any conspiracy theory all these
countries working together yeah exactly
that kind of international cooperation
you're telling me we got world peace
already
yeah what happened to the tucker girl
that went on tucker and said it was a
bioware
uh weapon that she got banned from
twitter and then oh yeah gone
i didn't even hear her back up to that
any any she she worked for the
university of hong kong
uh and i don't think she had anything to
do with any of the labs in china
so it really did seem like
look she's an expert well we hear what
she has to say i don't believe it
i don't think any president could have
come out of a covet as a shining beacon
of hope
nobody did nobody died look you had
nancy pelosi saying we should all go eat
dinner in chinatown
i think what did what didn't joe biden
say that trump's ban from from china was
i don't know if he used the word
xenophobic but he didn't say the ban was
he said he said something like we need
real leadership not trump's xenophobia
okay yeah yeah so i don't think anybody
really handled it properly but that said
trump is the president so
like he does have a special
responsibility here but what could he do
yeah i agree i mostly agree with you not
even not even covet but
when i hear people say like this is
trump's america and it's trump's fault
the rights and i'm like what should he
do
yeah like does that's not that's not how
the federal government works i don't
want to live
like i don't want the president just
going around yeah exactly there's like
this
fallacy that the president's like the
gunslinger that's going to go out and
kill the board and feed the family it's
his job is to sit back watch and make
sure no one does anything crazy
he has veto power and that's like it and
even then like he can let him get a
little crazy you know what i mean like
yeah the president is not supposed to
get involved with everything now now
that said
i i understand the arguments that he
should have been more involved
in some ways with kova 19 but it's all
really really complicated and so that's
what i'm saying i certainly don't blame
him for it but
i think that it's going to be easy to
use that against him in the media
though whatever advantage they may have
had they've been doing everything they
can to destroy
by advocating for and apologizing for
these riots and protests
what do you think trump could have done
better i'm not sure
um i'm not sure i think it's hard for me
to pinpoint anything specifically and
that's why i'm not even saying he
dropped the ball
but what i am saying is whenever
anything bad happens under anybody's
watch it's easy to see why they're going
to be blamed for it
yep and uh there's there's nothing to
compare it to
yeah there's no relativity here we we
people are looking at europe and they're
like look what happened in this country
and i'm like europe is
more densely populated but also you know
very very large and you're comparing
this one country
to like a bunch of different states like
the u.s compared to germany it's not a
question journey is microscopic
europe as a whole let's have a
conversation but then it's also got
double the population on the so it's
you can't do it you can't and they try
and it makes no sense and then i don't
know if you saw this but there was um
a camera i think it was nevada that
released the data about covet deaths
some of the people who had died with
covet had like end stage renal failure
and so people are pointing out if you
want to know how we got to 200
000 dead you need to understand that
some of these people were
really close to death as it was yeah it
is true that kovid caused it
but if you're someone with like end
stage renal failure and you're on your
deathbed and then you get coveted you're
gonna die
yeah you're gonna die if you get a cold
i i think what what's gonna have to be
done and i'm sure somebody's already
thought of this or is working on this
but
at the end of the year at the end of the
next two years they're really gonna need
to compile some compile some data
on net deaths like how many people died
overall
in this past year as compared to the
average and then we can see how many of
these coveted cases were just cove
adverse people who are going to die of
other diseases anyway
right like exacerbation i think is a
better word than cause because it's
someone with
end-stage renal failure whenever it gets
coveted it exacerbates the renal failure
yeah and of course we still don't want
them to get coveted absolutely no but
it's a different conversation then all
of these people
were just completely healthy and got
covered and then died yeah exactly
i i look i'll just put it it's really
the simple if you wanna have an argument
with me about why trump is bad
i'm listening man i'm out tell me tell
me bring it on but we don't get that
we just get like ridiculous nonsense no
real arguments about policy they say he
he failed us with covert what did he do
wrong
i i had my what what what did he do
wrong my parents had a trump sticker on
their back door when i went
back to their house one time i was like
what are you going to impeach them for
and neither of them had any idea so i
left
the ukraine several months later and the
sticker was gone oh nice there is
semblance of
nor of intelligence in even the most
whack you know not that they're the most
whacked
people when faced with the truth or or
like the reality of the situation
sometimes can see that
trump's not the demon he's kind of a
normal guy you can go look at my videos
and from my 2018 and i'm saying things
like look trump's not that bad but come
on man missile strikes in syria drone
drone strikes commando raids he's not
doing great you know relative to foreign
policy so as far as i'm concerned
then what's happened in the past year i
used to say specifically
like for me foreign policy is a big deal
yeah what what what are we spending our
money on why are we spending it why are
we getting involved in other people's
business
i understand sometimes like war happens
and there's like conflicts between
allies and people need our help
sure but what does it do with us yeah
and like why are we aiding the saudis in
yemen for example that's one thing that
that really upsets me about trump is
that he's kept that going
money he but he admitted it interesting
i didn't hear that blurted it out
he was like oh we're making tons of
money selling weapons
that's so horrible yeah i know that
boeing profit is like
yeah i i know that that what boeing
profited like 500 billion
servicing the f-12s that the saudi
arabian government is using which are
sometimes used to bomb like fishing
boats and fog
it's really evil stuff i mean the
weapons we supplied uh the russians
sorry to interrupt there yeah it's the
same weapons that al qaeda used well
i just wanna make sure i finish that
point yeah sure sure the past year trump
has been
historic peace deals he's got no new
wars
so we did have the you know he was he
was sort of playing the old game
of the existing wars no new wars we have
historic peace deals three historic
peace deals
we have the withdrawal from of the
troops i got very little complain about
anymore his character sure but that's
not the biggest factor it's not even the
top five i should clarify the weapons we
supplied i think was the afghani people
against the russians in the 80s oh yeah
the mujahideen yeah yes they
use those weapons against us yes yep
hey do you guys think that the the job
of the president is like
it no no good and should be changed like
too much power for one person that we
could formulate the power structure
better
i think trump is showing that the the
office can really be curtailed so long
as we have a congress willing to do it
like i i used to complain about the
expansion of executive authority
but the reality was congress just giving
the power and just agreeing but now that
we have this psychotic
you know two years of democrat impeach
screech and get nothing done now you can
really see how they've they just
they've screwed up trump's plans every
which way constantly they won't confirm
you know his appointees and things like
that
so you know his staff has been i think
it's like a historically thin
staff because they won't confirm a lot
of people he's trying to put on i can't
get specific on that
but i look at what they do and what
trump wanted to do and how they're
jamming him up to absurd degree and i'm
like you know part of me i'm kind of
like
i like the idea that the executive
branch is kind of getting some
comeuppance and getting their power
pulled back
but it's a little bit too much like
they've gone insane
it's one thing to be like we're not
gonna go to war and we're gonna pull our
troops back
to be like we're gonna impeach him
because you know he had a phone call
with some guy
so the fact that they have to go to
extreme psychotic lengths is just to
curtail the power of that
office well and it's all i think that's
that is how that's not what i'm saying
at all
like i'm saying they are they are
psychotic and now that they are they're
willing to actually use their powers to
you know dampen the executive functional
non-psychotic congress
is the president too powerful with their
executives i hear you well yeah i think
what we're kind of getting at is almost
like the right thing done for the wrong
reason it's good to limit that kind of
authority but the reasons they're doing
it for are dubious at best
but i would say that i think the federal
government in general just has far too
much power
i mean i'm certainly not as libertarian
as i used to be but i believe heavily in
a principle called subsidiarity which is
basically that
the most local possible authority to
handle something should be the one
handling it and we should only go up to
um a higher more more powerful or
centralized authority if we absolutely
have to
but that's not what we've done in this
country man over the past hundred years
so much has become federalized it's it's
a school system particularly yeah
and the idea of a public school system
is actually really insane to me the more
that i think about it something you take
for granted growing up but
the idea that we just sort of let the
government raise our kids is kind of
unthinkable especially in the united
states i mean
i'm not in favor of either of these
systems but in some ways i think you
could argue that a universal healthcare
system or the government being in charge
of healthcare would be more appropriate
to the american vision than the
government being in charge of educating
everyone's children
it's showing now too yeah with covid
being this the weirdness of kids having
to wear masks and et cetera et cetera
no no it's the kids in cubicles like
they've spaced all the chairs out and
then put them in these plastic
bins and i am i'm becoming a
more of a proponent of homeschooling
over time and it's not just because the
evidence has really borne out the fact
that homeschooling kids tend to perform
better
but it's the fact that when you really
examine the situation we don't even have
to look at this through the metric of
efficiency we just have to say
is making a child sit in a desk for six
to eight hours a day throughout their
entire childhood a good thing to do to
something
does that make them a productive adult
yeah it was it wasn't for me and this is
not me
i went to public school and look i had a
lot of great teachers i love
basically every teacher that i ever had
i'm not criticizing them but the system
is so broken and i just don't think it's
optimal
for educating our children and it's not
just that it isn't optimal i'm not just
making an efficiency argument i'm making
a moral argument it's not good for them
it wasn't good for me i got pushed
around and bullied you know hahaha
but like i would i would wait for other
kids in the class to figure it out and
they wouldn't call on me anymore i was
like i already got it come on let's move
on to the next problem let's fix let's
move move move
and i was in the wrong environment i
couldn't couldn't figure there are
places that kids can go if they're
smarter or dumber than other kids but
yeah you know for the most part you just
go to public school and that's
such a mess i think one of the biggest
problems we have in this country is that
from the ages of zero to five kids don't
do anything
hmm do do nothing was it kindergarten is
five years old yeah so what are you
doing through these extremely important
years of your life sitting around
watching tv well yeah that's a problem
if you just like sit your kid in front
of the tv then this is why you need a
tent of parents which is
part of why i'm a proponent of
homeschooling right because it's not as
if you just wait until that kid is five
education starts early and nobody is
ever going to understand a child's mind
better than their own parents will and
like homeschooling isn't always just one
parent homeschooling the kid you have
co-ops and you have different parents
getting together in the neighborhood and
and educating you know taking shifts
with the kids but i mean smaller
classroom sizes better test goes again i
i think all the evidence is
is there for it but i think peterson
said that the kids most formative
years were like one to three yeah really
yep
that's fascinating so i often ask people
like
uh if you want to figure out what you
want to do with the rest of your life
ask yourself what you were doing at a
certain age like what were you doing
when you were 13. most people don't have
a good answer about what they were doing
wow so i was talking to a friend of mine
and i said
what were you doing when you were 13
years old and they responded i don't
know hanging out with my friends and i
was like you want to open a bar
and she went oh i want to open a bar and
i'm like yeah because you want to hang
out with people
just want to sit around and drink so
open a bar and then people will come and
you'll be hanging out you'll be doing
what you did
i thought about this because i'm like i
know i know a bunch of people who went
on to become
like uh successful in various industries
skateboarding and music
and they've been doing it literally
their whole lives i i had this really
funny thought like
you know we say it's like riding a bike
it's oh it's so easy to ride a bike
isn't it
no it's easy because you were like you
know uh two or three years old and your
parents put you on the bike and then
had you ride with training wheels so
from your entire existence we've been
taught how to ride bikes guess what
you're an adult you can get on a bike
you know how to do it
imagine if instead of putting on a bike
or in addition to it
we taught them how to do math you showed
complex equations
and you started teaching them more and
more things or you gave them a skill
look riding a bike is is an important
thing i'm glad i know how to do it and
i i have memorized the cheat code for
teenage mutant ninja turtles too
i remember i've known this forever it's
b a b a up down b a left right b a spark
start why do i know that what is it it
gives you level select and ten lives
whoa
that game was tough why did i why do i
know that i haven't played that game in
like
25 years repetition in in early parts i
was
a little more impressionable that's what
i was i was playing a game and i was
taught this
and i never forgot it dude memorizing
phone numbers i don't know if you guys
used to oh yeah and i had this before
cell phone stuff i
have a book of all my friends phone
numbers and i just go down the list and
memorize
all the numbers that's awesome have them
on my head but it was great for like
memory retention yeah back in the day
when you need to know
whose number like how old are you james
i'm 25.
do you so you don't do you no i remember
having to memorize people's numbers i
mean i didn't get my first cell phone
until high school so
yeah quite a bit for them and now i
don't remember anybody's phone number
no never you just lose it yeah i just
remember like
like 50 to 100 phone numbers yeah it's
like oh yeah now it's
you know what's gonna happen is i was
watching an episode of uh outer limits
we're just gonna have our brains plugged
in like
or something what if the power goes out
yeah then you'll then you'll be sitting
there like
oh no man i really hope not i really
hope not i'm not volunteering
for that if it ever becomes a reality
because i wonder i'm skeptical of the
fact that we have a really could
interface with the human brain in that
way have you seen the neural link
no oh there's a elon did like uh a
i don't know what you call it but like
he showed pigs that had the knurling
implanted and that it actually functions
and it was like that movie gamer where
um was it was a guy named michael c hall
is that his name
where he did like the puppet thing and
then all the people are just forced to
do the same motions
so like elon plugs in his neural link
and then he plugs it into the pig and
then he goes like this and the pigs
start like marching and he's like
i'm kidding i was thinking maybe oh of
power going out
is like an archaic idea that will no
longer exist in the future like they
have these nuclear
batteries that are in like carbon glass
so you may just have endless amounts of
electricity
forever that can't be solar flared out
yeah i don't know it's so theoretical to
me i just
i'm just so skeptical of all that i feel
like so many predictions whenever we
make predictions for the future this is
going to sound
so um is actually going to sound really
really uh how should i put this
vapid but look i mean the reality is
either people like way over predict
their way under predict
when you like look at a magazine like
from the early 1900s what will the year
1909 look like i thought firefighters
would be flying
yeah yeah i remember i saw one where
everyone was transported around in these
like large hot air balloons it's very
cool looking but every time i hear a
prediction
of the future i just i look and i think
about that i think i already know the
answer but would you plug your brain
into the neural net 100 no never
would you consider it would you wait no
i just wouldn't i don't think i would do
it
you don't want to join the borg
absolutely not i understand that
resistance is futile exactly yeah
life not for me this is why we need the
second amendment
yeah no no but what if neural link gives
you the ability to
like experience different worlds and
like virtual reality and
this world's enough is it yeah but you
can't fly around shooting laser beams
out of your eyes and throwing fireballs
at the
at the the you know the evil you can't
you can't you don't know what
that's right what if it like made you
able to draw your art faster and better
oh that's a good question i i would
still just want to use the computer what
if you could download like
jiu jitsu and then you just like you
know like matrix and you just click the
thing and then you're like
whoa and then you just knew everything i
feel like there would be so many
unintended consequences and and
implications to that that i can't even
begin to comprehend
that i could i just can't agree what i'm
afraid of is that other people will plug
in and then they'll start doing like
for for you for instance they'd start
drawing and they just so many people
would be able to do exactly what you did
but better faster
that you'd fall behind communism uh oh
that's the digital communism
yeah neural link everyone would be the
same i would i would plug in you'd plug
in and then
we would sync and i would have all of
your abilities oh my god now it'd be
like now i am the freedom
steal from me that's exactly why i don't
plug in i want anyone to steal my ideas
the whole reason i'm afraid here thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 p.m so come back to
check us out when we go live don't
forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you